[ MOTOR WHIRRING ]
Narrator: THE LAWNMOWER.
HOW DOES THIS BACKYARD WORKHORSE
CUT THROUGH THE THICKEST GRASS
ON ALL TERRAINS
WITHOUT JAMMING?
MORE THAN 350 COMPONENTS
WORK TOGETHER.
THE ENGINE TURNS THE BLADES
50 TIMES A SECOND
TO PULVERIZE THE GRASS.
IF IT SLOWS DOWN,
THE GRASS WON'T CUT CLEANLY,
AND THE MOWER WILL CLOG UP.
SO THERE'S A HIDDEN MECHANISM
TO KEEP THE BLADE SPINNING
AT EXACTLY THE RIGHT SPEED.
IT'S CALLED THE GOVERNOR,
AND IT'S THE LAWNMOWER'S
CRUISE CONTROL.
IT USES FLYWEIGHTS
TO DETECT THE SPEED
OF THE BLADE.
IF THE CRANKSHAFT SLOWS DOWN,
THE FLYWEIGHTS DECELERATE,
FALL INWARDS,
AND TRIGGER A LEVER...
...TO OPEN THE THROTTLE
AND PUMP IN MORE FUEL.
THIS BOOSTS THE ENGINE'S POWER
AND SPINS THE BLADE BACK UP
TO THE PERFECT CUTTING SPEED
OF 3,000 TIMES A MINUTE.
NOW, IF A BLADE HITS A ROCK
AT OVER 200 MILES PER HOUR,
IT CAN CARRY ON CUTTING
WITH HARDLY A SCRATCH.
WITH SO MUCH METAL
CRAMMED UNDER ITS SKIN,
YOU'D EXPECT THIS MACHINE
TO FEEL HEAVY.
SO HOW DO MOWERS
MAKE PUSHING UPHILL EASY?
THE SECRET
IS SELF-POWERED WHEELS.
ONE ENGINE DRIVES BOTH THE BLADE
AND THE WHEELS.
AS THE BLADE SPINS
AT 3,000 TIMES A MINUTE,
A BELT CARRIES
THIS BREAKNECK SPEED
TO THE GEARBOX,
WHICH STEPS DOWN THE SPEED
SEVEN TIMES.
A CABLE CONNECTED TO A LEVER
ON THE HANDLEBAR
ALLOWS THE DRIVER
TO FINE-TUNE THE SPEED
BY ADJUSTING THE BELT'S TENSION.
THESE INNOVATIONS MAKE SURE
THIS FOUR-WHEEL DRIVE
ALWAYS MOVES
AT THE PERFECT PACE.